elle
autre grand mère m'a dit que son
petit-fils et avocat à cincinnati
spécialisé dans l'environnement
je crois que vous n'avez pas compris je
suis avocat d'affaires donc je défends
les entreprises de chimie
maintenant vous allez me défendre vous
en avez perdu combien 190 vous avez
perdu 190 vaches vous allez pas me dire
que c'est normal aussi
c'est juste une petite affaire pour un
ami de la famille et au moins on aura
aidé quelqu'un le fermier ou toi c'est
les produits chimiques qui font ça je
comprends pas tous dans leurs archives
on nous cache des choses ce produit
chimique ça fait quoi si on en buvait au
war c'est comme de demander et gia
valable de géographes
imaginons que ce qui fait mourir tout
ses vaches
c'est quelque chose qui est dans l'eau
du robinet chez dupont promettre une vie
meilleure grâce à la chimie
ça fait partie de notre adn je tenais
vraiment à [ __ ] ta carrière en laye
tout ça pour un bouseux il faut que tu
me disent qu'ils passaient le prix du
riz dupont a délibérément empoisonné
plus de soixante-dix mille citoyens
pendant quarante vous saviez pourtant
vous n'avez rien fait tu veux prendre
tout ce que tu sais et utiliser sa
contre le géant américain de l'industrie
chimique tenter un informateur c'est pas
vrai
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai 6
ils ont l'argent sur le pouvoir et ils
n'hésiteront pas à les utiliser contre
vous je le sais j'ai été dans leur camp
ils veulent que tu me dises d'arrêter
l'état est captif de dupont et ils
étaient prêts à renoncer à tout ça pour
était un inconnu qui distingue le
système est truqué ils veulent nous
faire croire qu'il nous protège
[Musique]